what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful intelligent
planet eva lova marinova pompliano i
don't know what is going on
with her hair today but i like it
don't forget that blockfly is now the
sponsor of lunch money go to blockfy.com
pomp and you can use all their products
8.6
apy in an interest bearing account you
can buy and sell crypto on the crypto
exchange or you can deposit crypto and
take out a us dollar loan against your
crypto collateral
blockfi.com literally somebody the other
day walked by me on the street in miami
and as they walked by me they just
yelled out blockfire.com and played an
island
ridiculous it was hysterical i then
texted zach zach lost it so
whoever that was i appreciate you all
right let's go
news today speaking of blockfy.com
blogify lands a 350 million dollar
series d at a 3 billion evaluation for
its fast growing crypto lending platform
guess who led it okay hold on
guess who led it who it was
it was bain capital dst
me and tagging global
but also my friends bracket capital
shout out to jahan ateed yalda at
bracket capital
morgan creek digital also participating
mark yusko jason williams
what up and many others like susquehanna
and vallar
bench i participated james and drew in
spirit
so what are you doing rocket ships get
on board
so why is block why does wifi need this
much money first of all what are they
going to do growing over 500 employees
now around the world 225
000 users over 15 billion dollars in
assets on the platform
50 million dollars a month
a month 50 million dollars a month in
revenue
let's roll zach flory the rest of the
block by team are absolutely
killing it they built an amazing
business obviously and anytime you can
get a
who's who at the table of all these
investors
something's going right so i am bullish
bullish bullish what's next
all right nfts which stand for
non-fungible
tokens uh my friend caroline thought it
was non-fundable
tokens non-fungible like the fungi all
right
um so an nft by the artist people sold
at christie's for over
60 million dollars making it the most
expensive nft
ever sold at auction people are losing
here's a life hack if you're my friend
you stay winning that is a life hack if
you're my friend
you stay winning people what up
boy let's go mike absolutely killing it
i said it if you watch the interview
that i did with him i released it on
monday
i've been talking to him for a while now
he's asked me he said what do you think
is going to go for and i said over 50
million dollars and he laughed
he was laughing at me he was like no way
i was like over 50 million dollars
well guess who's laughing now people
and i'm laughing because i'm proud of
you i'm happy for you shout out to
people
absolutely amazing 60 plus million
dollars first nft auction at christie's
that's what i'm talking about
that's how you disrupt the art world he
said
uh basically he's saying that as soon as
i saw it i saw it as
this massive massive potential for this
as a platform for digital ownership of a
bunch of different things not just
our people said moving forward i think
this will be seen as an
alternate form of asset class people are
obsessed with nfts do we think that it's
a bubble though
no why we're all underestimating how big
this is going to be
this is going to be massive
absolutely can you do a very quick
people have been asking
description about nfts and why they're
valuable
forget about the technology for a second
the whole idea is intellectual property
is one of the most valuable assets in
the world but previously it's been
nearly impossible to figure out what
something is worth
the way that it's figured out is usually
lawyers go in a room and they negotiate
with each other and then they come up
with a contract and then they all sign
it and that's how
intellectual property is decided what
it's worth so think of let's say for
example the nba
goes into a room and they negotiate with
the tv
networks and they come with a price and
so it's a couple billion dollars a year
in tv
right so if you want to take our ip our
video and you want to play on your
network you got to pay us a couple
billion dollars
well now what the nba is doing is the
nba is cutting up
highlights and they're bringing it to
the free market to the open market
they're saying to everyone out there how
much will you pay for this highlight
and people are paying literally hundreds
of thousands of dollars for a single
moment it's called the nba top
shot there's a wall street journal
article on it right now yes and so the
whole
idea now is what you're doing is you're
getting out of that inefficient market
of two people going in a room and
negotiating over a contract and instead
you're allowing free market dynamics to
take over where now you can auction it
highest bidder who wants it
previously you couldn't even get in the
room to negotiate if
and then you had to have billions of
billions of dollars now you can show up
and say i'll pay 20
for that if i'm the person who'll pay
the most forth then i get it right if
somebody says i'll pick 200 000 then
they get it
and so ultimately what we're seeing is
we're seeing intellectual property be
repriced in the market
all the technology all that other stuff
none of it matters right
all of it is going to get figured out i
don't know where it's going to end up
maybe it'll get built on top of bitcoin
ethereum flow all these other
blockchains i have
no clue where it's going to end up but
what i do know is that when you can now
take intellectual property and expose it
to a free market and get price discovery
it is going to prove that we've all been
drastically undervaluing
all of this all these assets
intellectual is an
asset and so now we're about to see an
explosion in interest
and i can't wait for the entrepreneurs
and innovators to figure out how to take
this technology
marry it with these assets and bring it
to the world beautiful
explanation i get it now i understand it
all all the fungible tokens
did i tell you guys that block 5 raised
350 million dollars and my friend beeple
sold some for 60 mil today all right
buzzfeed
is looking to go public by linking up
with a spec
uh the media company which recently
acquired huff post and caught a bunch of
people laid off a bunch of people
yesterday
is in talks to merge with eight hundred
ninety fifty
fifth avenue partners which is named
after the fictional avengers
mansion um financial terms were not
reported
buzzfeed declined to comment but
recently
um um buzzfeed ceo jonah peretti
said that the cuts that they made to the
staff
were part of an effort to fast track the
path to profitability for the newly
acquired
property i mean it's pretty common for a
media company to acquire another media
company and start slashing
inefficiency okay so what do we think
about buzzfeed going public
via spec good luck
we'll see okay uh israeli pension giant
uh made put 100 million into
the grayscale bitcoin trust
uh it's the the company is called out
out
schuler has sunk 100 million into the
grayscale bitcoin trust
that uh it's one of the largest
investment houses in israel with over 50
billion dollars in assets
under management wow
you know what that noise is that's them
all capitulating
every single institution every single
financial
organization every single corporation
every single
pension fund every single insurance
company
and every single central bank is going
to buy
bitcoin put it in the receipts hold on
to it and when we wind back the clocks
in ten years i'm gonna say told you so
told you so told you so
okay let's go let's go where's my guy
moist
i just got time for moist where's moist
all right hold on
um all right so no ask lunch from any
questions we can take the questions
ask ellen in the comments below the
first one question we have is from kevin
bettencourt he said pomp what's a piece
of life advice you can give someone
leaving the military
adjusting to civilian life and changing
careers
oh is it to me yes
don't settle you you have the one skill
that all these other soft dudes and
girls don't have you got mental
toughness
you got leadership training and you got
experience working in high stress
environments
and the thing that is most missing in
everyone who went through an academic
career
is that they might be geniuses the first
time something goes wrong they're curled
up underneath their desk crying like
little babies saying oh my god somebody
come save us
you literally have the advantage the
same things that made you great as a
soldier
will make you great in the workplace and
don't settle you can literally do
anything you possibly want in the world
and there's gonna be a bunch of people
along the way that tell you no you can't
that's it that's my advice that's good
that's good advice all right so moist
time moist counter
yesterday if you may remember we said a
commenter named gabriella
she she was asking you know how old is
moist
what we got going on here but she ended
up watching the episode with her little
brother
who seemed to not appreciate that
comment but she says i'm in my 20s by
the way
moist moist vomiting
all right hold on but moist is like 20
20. um
day 20 of commenting for moist yesterday
so today is 21
he says all my socks are either white or
black so it is really hard to wear two
different ones on accident that being
said i did that very recently
accidentally
i didn't notice it but one of my black
socks was more of a faded than the other
much more faded than the other some
person i was with pointed it out to me
and i just went on with my business
wondering why
they were observing my feet so closely
seriously i was wearing pants
how did she notice that also gabriella
was it
i'm 20 and my dms are open
i cannot be helping moist find love
gabriella if you don't
message moist we gonna have problems and
now i know you got 12 year old brother
don't make me call him he sounds like
the boss of the house
moist gang hashtag unleash the moisture
i got 20 year olds up in the comments
section all trying to meet up
for some tinder grinder whatever you
guys all are doing i just cannot believe
that this show is helping moist find
love
well because moist actually has
different pairs of socks moist actually
that happens to me every once in a while
but usually it's because my shirt is
faded with my black pants and then
people are like
that is weird that that person noticed
the faded socks since you were wearing
pants that is very strange
maybe it's attention to detail you never
want to get anybody mad at attention for
detail all right i got a question
moist big question okay
peanut butter jelly which one goes on
first peanut butter or jelly don't mess
it up peanut butter jelly does the
peanut butter go on the bread first
or the jelly this is an important
important question
that's it for today gabriella moist
you guys are coming together i want to
be
the priest at the wedding if if all goes
well
can we have gabrielle in the show too
i don't want to start to uh effectuate
dates but if y'all go on a date and take
a selfie i might post it on here yeah i
might do that
okay all right guys good luck and
goodbye
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends